In this video, we
continue our exploration
of quantities of
interest associated
with the short-term
behavior of Markov chain.
This time, we suppose that we
have a Markov chain composed
of a single recurrent
class, such as this one.
Here, we have our
recurrent class.
And these are transient states.
We also assume that
we're interested
in a specific recurrent
state-- let's say 9.
So this is my state s.
And we will assume that
the Markov chain starts
from a given initial
state, state i,
and assume that i is 1.
Now the question we ask is,
given that you started in 1,
how long is it going to take
to reach 9 for the first time?
We know this is a
recurrent class,
so we know that the
Markov chain eventually
will come to that class
and circulate here.
So you know that the Markov
chain will get to that state 9.
You are interested
in knowing when
it does so for the first time.
Of course, we don't
know for sure.
This is random.
It is a random variable.
And let's try to calculate
the expected value
of this random variable.
More precisely, this is
what we would like to do.
We would like to find the
mean first passage time from i
to s, from any starting state i.
Here, we're going to
illustrate that with 1.
And mathematically, this
is what we have here.
So here again, what you have
is that the Markov chain
started in state i, at time 0.
And now you are looking
at this set here.
And the set records
all the time n such
that your Markov chain, Xn,
is in the state s of interest.
So out of this set, you're
looking at the minimum, n,
that verifies that.
So this is going to
be a random variable.
And you take the
expected value of that.
And this is what we call the
mean first passage time from i
to s.
Again, this is the
expected number of steps
in order to get from i
to s for the first time.
So how do we go about
calculating such a quantity?
Well, let us think a little bit.
We are looking at
the event that you
will visit 9 from 1
for the first time.
What happened
after visiting 9 is
of no relevance in
our calculation.
In other words, our calculation
will never involve this arc
and will not involve
this arc either.
Because in order
for the Markov chain
to traverse this
arc or this one,
it would have to visit 9 first.
So what it means is that we
can forget about this arc,
and we can forget about
this arc-- in a sense,
that they don't matter
in the calculation
of the mean first
passage time to s.
Now, removing
these arcs entirely
means that you would
have to increase
the probability of that self
transition from 0.2 to 1.
So what do you get?
Well, you get this
following graph.
We have removed
these arcs, and we
have increased the
probability 0.2 here to 1.
And again, we have
argued that calculating
the mean first passage time
from i to s in this graph
is the same as doing the
same thing for this graph.
But here, we have a
very special structure.
We have only one recurrent
state left, which is state 9.
And that state is
an absorbing state.
All the other
state-- this one was
transient, transient, transient.
This one becomes
a transient state.
And this one is also a transient
state in this new transition
probability diagram.
So we get a situation where
we have one single absorbing
state, and we are
interested in calculating
the probability starting from
i to reach that absorbing state
and also the number
of steps it takes
to do that, which is what we
did in the previous video.
So let us repeat what
we had seen before.
So this is going to be the
unique solution to this system.
t of s equals 0, of course.
Since you start from
s, you are in s.
And so the amount of time
it takes to get to s is 0.
And otherwise, for all the
other states that are not s,
this is the resulting system
of equation that we have.
And the unique
solution of this system
gives you the result of finding
the expected amount of time
to go to the absorbing state s.
So using this
simple trick, we've
been able to use the
previous calculation
to calculate something else.
Let us consider a
related question, which
we called the mean
recurrence time of s.
Here, let's go back
to the original graph.
And this is our state s.
And now the question
is the following--
given that you are in s,
what is the amount of time
it will take for
the Markov chain
to return to s for
the first time?
So for this question, the
Markov chain is currently in 9.
And you ask yourself,
how long is it
going to take, once you
leave 9, to return to 9?
Here again, we
don't know for sure.
It's a random variable.
And we are interested
in the expectation
of that random variable--
in other words,
in the expected number of
steps it takes in order
to get back to 9
once you are in 9.
And this is what we mean by
the mean recurrence time of s.
And mathematically,
this is what it is.
It is almost the same formula
as the one that you had here,
except that here you
have n greater than/equal
to 1 as opposed to n
greater than/equal to 0.
It simply means that you're not
interested in the first time
that you're in s,
because you start from s.
So you want to have n
greater than or equal to 1. n
equals 0 would not work.
ts star would have been 0.
So how would you
solve that problem?
Well, here again, you use the
same trick that we used before.
And think in terms of tree.
Let's look at the
Markov chain in state 9.
What can happen next?
From 9, it can go to
3 or it can go to 5.
Or it can jump on itself.
So this is with a
probability 0.2.
This is with a probability 0.2.
And this is with a
probability of 0.6.
And now, after you
make one transmission--
so let's-- you are in 3 now--
what is the time to get to 9?
Well, it's exactly
t3-- where the t
is, the solution here
of that previous system.
What about from 5?
t5.
And what about from 9?
Well, t9.
And t9 was 0.
So from that tree,
what you have is
t9 star will be 0.2 times t3
plus 0.6 times t5 plus 0.2
times t9 plus, of
course, 1, because you
have done one transition.
Where, again, this value of
t3, t5, and t9 are the ones
corresponding to
this solution here.
So of course, t9 is 0.
So what we have shown
here, that in general,
this is actually
what you would have.
And this is exactly what
we have written here.
ts star is 1 plus the summation
of psj of t of j, where t of j
is the solution to this system.
So again, you started from 9.
You have to do a
transition first.
You can do a transition
unto yourself.
You can go to 3 or
you can go to 6.
After that transition,
which stands for the number
1 here, what happens
is you're trying
to find the solution
to this system, which
is the mean first passage time,
from the current state where
you are, to 9.
And then when you put
these two things together,
you get the mean
recurrence time of 9.